The outcry to regulate big tech
companies is getting louder! There are
several questions. One is: Should sites
like Facebook be held accountable for
their site's content? Yes... by their
customers. Customers know more about the
good and bad of the content than do
government regulators, and government
regulators have their own agendas and
biases. So we should proceed cautiously
before regulating content. Should
government limit big tech's collection and
use of big data? This question should
become moot after a few years, as
blockchain is likely to give customers
control of their data. Between now and
then, the best thing to do for customers
is provide them with transparency. Should
the government break up big tech? That
makes no practical sense. Which of your
friends do you want kicked off
Facebook? Do you want your Google
searches diverted to Ask.com? Or your
Amazon purchases diverted to Walmart? If
the government did break up one or more
companies, customer choice would put them
back together. What's the bottom line? In
fast moving markets, customers and
competition are the best regulators.
Do
you think big tech should be more
regulated? Let us know your comments. Also,
let us know what other topics you'd like
for our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.